thank you for joining us I'm John
langler we start in the East Valley
Charleston and lamb is back open right
now after a shooting by Metro Police
earlier this morning but officers say
they only took that action after the
suspect kidnapped three people and
pointed a gun in their Direction 8 news
now reporter Lorna Grady has the details
Metro Police say this is a
one-armed
three victims they got the call just
before 1am from Boulder City police
Boulder City police received a 9-1-1
text message from a woman stating she'd
been kidnapped officers located that
vehicle at Owens at Hollywood at
approximately
2 A.M in the morning and forced the
kidnapper's car to a stop near
Charleston and lamb boulevards the
suspect was armed with a firearm inside
the vehicle police say the gunman
pointed his weapon towards a victim
officer discharged his weapon striking
the suspect the suspect was tenant to by
Medical on scene and was transported to
Area Hospital and is in critical
condition police say two of the three
other individuals were taken to the
hospital their condition was not shared
with us this is an ongoing investigation
the identity of the officer involved
should be released in 48 hours near
Charleston and lamb Lauren negretti 8
News Now